[Music]
let me start by giving you an overview
of the agenda of tomorrow's college
meeting
the college will adopt a package of
measures linked to the protection of
nature delivering on our green deal it
includes several proposals and
communications
on soil protection deforestation and
waste shipments
executive vice president franz
timmermans and virginia cinque vicius
will present the package
to you tomorrow during a press
conference
immediately after the college meeting
we will also organize an off the record
technical briefing for you on this
tomorrow afternoon
after the press conference
the college will also discuss a
communication focused on the review of
competition policy ensuring it is fit
for new challenges
executive vice president margrethe
vestage will give a press conference on
this at 1 pm on thursday
and now over to balash who has good news
on the
budget front
palace
online
good afternoon
the european commission has decided
today to invest over 1.1 billion euros
into seven large-scale projects under
the innovation fund
these grants aim to bring breakthrough
technologies to the market in energy
intensive industries hydrogen carbon
capture use and storage and renewable
energy
the selected projects are located in
belgium italy finland france the
netherlands norway spain and sweden
they were chosen for their ability to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions compared
to conventional technologies their
innovative nature and their capacity for
quick deployment
the selective projects will help to
decarbonize industrial processes in the
fields of chemicals steel
cement refineries and power and heat
more information about the projects and
the procedures is in our daily news and
in a press release thank you
thank you
okay thank you eric
i would like to ask a question about
yesterday's foreign affairs council
i think the high representative talked
also about the administration in
bosnia-herzegovina
and stress the importance of keeping
it's a united single country but as you
know there is a constitutional crisis in
bosnia vienna
and we have heard that some member
states even raise the issue of possible
sanctions
against subsequent republica and its
its leader
i wonder if the action service
is going to say to explore this
possibility
to next
foreign thank you
thank you moses for the question i think
the main results of the fac and main
agreements made by the foreign ministers
were announced yesterday by high
representative borrel on bosnia and
herzegovina i can only recall that uh
the situation in the country is serious
we take this crisis very serious that's
why we are increasing our engagement
also together with uh with partners so
it's not only the eu the individual
member states of the european union but
we also do it together with our friends
from united states
and when it comes to the question of
sanctions there is nothing new to report
i can only recall that we have a
sanctions framework in place already
since 2011.
and
in the light of the recent developments
in the country and the secessionist
rhetoric and divisive rhetoric and
unacceptable
rhetoric and some actions that are
undermining the unity of the state
institutions
the ministers discussed the situation
and all options are currently on the
table
thank you very much are there other
questions on uh bossier herzegovina
peter
please only keep your hand raised in the
interaxio
if your question concerns this topic
okay i see one hand raise
moritz this is on this go ahead
uh excuse me do you yeah yeah it is
it is not not on on uh on bosnia i'm
sorry i wanted to put my hand down for
bosnia it's a different topic okay all
right okay all right thanks
so do i see no further questions on this
are there other questions for peter on
foreign affairs for us today
so moist you have a question on foreign
affairs then
first and
it's on on nordstrom 2 um
the decision by the german regulators to
suspend the certification of north
stream to
argue for now
um is
i would be interested in a reaction by
the commission to this decision and
which conditions in your point of view
have to be met in order to give approval
to the operation of the pipeline
and lastly do you worry that this will
exacerbate the energy crisis in europe
gas markets are
reacting quite negatively to this
announcement gas prices are up by about
10 percent
thank you
thank you well this is certainly not
really a foreign affairs
question but since nobody else has
raised their hand for foreign affairs
issue um we'll consider this chapter
closed and move over then to energy and
i passed the floor to tim on this
question
hi there hi again yeah so thanks for for
the question maurice um i i don't have
very much that i can say at this stage
so the commission takes note of the
decision which was announced this
morning by the bundesligan tour
which is part of the the ongoing
national process uh as part of the
certification of of the north stream two
pipeline
um as you know when that process uh has
been completed by the german regulator
uh they will submit a um draft
certification decision
to the european commission and at that
stage um it will be over to us and to
have our say
on the issue but for now we can simply
take note of the of the ongoing process
in germany and have nothing to add i'm
certainly also not going to
speculate on on what this means for for
markets and prices that's just not
something that we that we do
thank you um and let me make uh clear
that we certainly are not going to be
commenting every step of the way on the
process underway in germany when it
comes to the certification of north
stream 2 as to energy prices
you know what the position of the
european commission is on this we
presented the communication on this uh
which was then the subject of
discussions in the in the european
council
other questions on this issue david
[Music]
if the fact that the the
the company should have
should be based in germany is a
requirement
of the eu law
or
the origin of this decision
has to do with the national law of
germany
i don't know if you it's clear that you
can answer
i don't know the answer myself i don't
know tim can you answer that
question i mean all i can say at this
stage is that this is a step in in the
procedure in germany and there's there's
nothing more we can comment for the
moment
yeah but i think in terms of determining
whether it is a german or an eu
requirement we can come back to you we
can come back to you on that
um
david
um
i'm okay yeah we i won't make a further
comment but we'll investigate and come
back to you on that
any other questions on this issue yes
uh hi jess parker from bbc news i just
wanted to check can you tell us exactly
when the commission was was told i think
they might have got some advance notice
of this uh decision and is there any
any indication you can give us as to
what the knock-on effect will be for for
when the
certification will pass into the
commission's hands
well i'm not sure that the german
regulator has to inform us of every step
of the way but let's check with tim
uh i don't know if they were obliged to
inform us but they they did inform us as
a courtesy so we were aware um just
shortly before the decision was taken
uh in terms of what it means for for the
process and and the
that four month clock you would again
have to check with the german regulator
how they how they see that having an
impact on the process
thank you other questions on this
other questions on energy in general
no so
are there other questions for us today
um
i have st
hetta
if i not mistaken
um yes you're right it's me hi from the
friday's news agency std hassan
um i have a question for tim as well i
guess it's about the innovation fund um
news that was just announced i was
hoping to hear a bit more about the
projects that are
being funded by that and especially the
finnish one thank you
tim
notes and to find my speed button at the
same time
on this um so the the finished project
[Music]
is
linked to a
refinery in in porvu
and it will demonstrate two ways of
producing clean hydrogen and through
renewable energy and by capturing co2
and then permanently storing that co2 in
the north sea
i'm happy to provide some more
information bilaterally if you need more
details
thank you are there other questions
for tim on
the
projects funded by the innovation fund
that we have just
announced
that is not the case
so we move to
other subjects
oliver
um well maybe i'll take this off then
it's clear
just um a question is there any update
any new movements on the um
um polish and hungarian um
you know plans
and uh staying geographically in that
corner of um europe uh the europe the
polish government now announced it's
gonna build a wall on
the border with belarus the commission
always said it's not gonna fund walls
lots of uh
ministers of about a dozen or more
countries say they should at the same
time you still have no access to the
border so basically you are currently
politically speaking in a lose-lose
proposition you have no access neither
the commission nor frantics or anyone
else to the border and at the same time
your
your tenant that the
u-budget should not fund walls has no
impact on walls being actually erected
on the portal
what you make of this situation
and do you plan to put pressure on the
polish government to actually let either
somebody from the commission or from
frontex or from the asylum support
office
get access to the border um and sort of
get a get your own assessment of what's
really happening there thank you
oliver thank you oliver on your first
question the answer is that contacts uh
continue on the uh national plans of
both poland and hungary but we have
nothing new to and to report
on the second question let me remind you
that we have said that
eu funds our position is that eu funds
should not be used to construct uh walls
which is not the same as saying that
physical barriers cannot be cannot be
built but on contact with the polish
authorities
let me pass the floor to a delbert
thank you very much oliver um and maybe
let me start by
by saying that i am
not completely sure if we can we can
really conflate the two questions from
from our perspective the question of
walls uh and permanent infrastructure at
the border is is not quite the same as
the the more immediate issue of how to
manage this particular situation and
and access to to the border
when it comes to the latter
we continue to insist with the polish
authorities that both
the access
both
support by eu agencies on the ground
would be something that that would be
very useful and
the there is no
news
about a possible trip of european
commission officials to the border and
also there we can continue to emphasize
to the polish authorities that
we would find such a such a visit very
valuable
thank you are there
oliver follow up
thank you um
well i would posit that these two
questions are related politically in so
far as it's obvious that at least the
polish government doesn't want the
european commission to have anything to
do with how it's running things on its
border and you could very well argue
that this is sort of not very supportive
to your own
um
assumption that the european commission
should actually you know be in the
driving seat of external border policies
and so forth have a related question do
that do you think it would be a good
idea for the independent press to get
access to the polish border to the
polish belarusian border and if so what
you intend to do
in order to make that happen thank you
thank you oliver um we have repeatedly
emphasized uh and particularly
commissioner johansson has done it in in
numerous on numerous occasions the
importance of transparency in the
management of of the situation of course
uh the
the media as well as as well as
international organizations civil
society have an important uh role to
play um so their their presence of
course uh on the on the ground would be
also something that's very welcome
other questions for adelbero on the
situation at the border with belarus
alberto
from intaccio
if it's on this
yeah
no it's about the european court of
justice and the letter if there is any
response to the mp letter asking to stop
poland receiving covet recovery funds do
you have something to say about this
officially
so it's not a question for um ad albert
but since it's linked to the question
which whatever asked let me say that we
indeed i can confirm receipt of the
letter and will uh answer in due time
and as i said in my answer to uh to
oliver we are
in contact of course with the polish
authorities the discussions continue but
there is nothing that we can add at this
stage are there other questions for
adelberg on the situation at the border
with
belarus
angela
uh yes good morning thanks felix yes
it's
on the same topic i wanted to know uh
how are you what's the procedure to
control to check that european funds
don't go to
uh the construction of wars for example
there are these other 25 million euros
going to
the managing of frontiers are you gonna
how are you going to uh control that
they are not uh they would not be used
for walls and and the other question is
uh what do you intend for permanent
infrastructures uh
um i remember that you were talking
about this maybe last week as well but i
wanted to be sure it is not walls it is
not bad wires uh
it could be drones what could it be and
do you see the risk
also going back to the checks and the
controls of the money
that the
result of any
form of control uh
runs the risk to to to come late after
the election awards thanks
thank you um well as you know the eu
manages a very
sophisticated budget
and therefore has many many procedures
in place that enable it to control
the use of the funds both
during the
the lifespan of a program or after the
lifetime of a program with procedures
if needed to
either not pay
parts of the amounts that are foreseen
or to recover the money i don't think
we're going to go into a technical
briefing here as to how exactly those
procedures work they depend on the
nature of the program the management
mode etc etc but generally speaking the
eu of course controls
the use of eu funds and
afterwards the court of auditors of
course is also there to um to control
these uh these funds i will pass the
floor to adelberg on your second
question uh thank you very much and i i
may perhaps add that since this question
came up in
in the midday briefing i believe last
week we also um at the request of one of
your colleagues uh we've done a bit more
research about the specific procedures
applicable to the internal security fund
as well as to its successor the border
visa
and border management and visa
instrument
and we are ready to provide you with
further details still about how exactly
these
controls work for these two funds when
it comes to the types of
projects that that are financed at the
at the
eu border types of infrastructure
we in fact published last week a
fact sheet which provides
a lot of useful information there
but maybe as a highlight i can um i can
emphasize that uh the the funding that
is allocated to this issue is is very
very substantial uh for the current
multi-annual financial framework we are
looking at uh 6.4 billion euro that will
be allocated for border management and
visa policy and that is in addition to
funding for frontex
which is of the same order of magnitude
so um we are really looking at at very
very significant funding for available
to member states and the types of
infrastructure and action that we
finance include construction expansion
of border crossing points expansion of
technical border protection systems and
indeed you mentioned for example
drones but there are also other types of
devices including aircraft vehicles
transportation video surveillance
systems
i.t platforms radio communication
systems and others and i will be very
happy to send you a link to our
factsheet which also has a link to a
brochure which then gives very specific
examples of
of projects that have been financed
all right i see no further questions for
adelberg on this issue either in the
press room or on the interactual
platform
so thank you
are there other issues for us today
jessica go ahead
sorry i'm going to be a bit predictable
i just wanted to ask about fishing and i
just wanted to ask are
technical talks still actually happening
between the uk
france and the commission it's it's been
a bit quiet on that front for a few days
so just an update on whether talks are
happening and whether you guys can give
us any
indication as to where the numbers are
at on licenses thank you
vivian is coming up but i think it's
more to get the exercise than anything
else because the answer is yes talks
continue between the commission and the
united kingdom and no we don't have much
that we can say but sorry anything you
want to add vivian just thank you for
this opportunity for the exercise
sorry for that jessica
um
any other questions for for vivian
on uh
on on questions um related to her
portfolio
particular
no okay
thank you very much vivian i could have
spared you that
we no no no no update sorry about that
but we're not going to provide uh as i
said as we've said a couple of times
detailed information each step of the
way but yes we can confirm that the
discussions are ongoing between the
commission and the united kingdom
okay i think ana fandensky has been
asking for the floor for a while in the
chat
go ahead
if you're still with us anna
can you hear me now
we can indeed go ahead and be glad okay
thank you for giving me a flow i have a
question on situation in austria
actually how the european commission
defends the article 2
and i remind everyone that article 2
clearly states
that are european union guarantees uh
freedom democracy equality
uh and respect of human rights including
rights of person belonging to minority
because now in austria 65
of citizens are vaccinated so there is
minority which is unvaccinated and how
you defend their rights in line of the
article 2 of the treaty
ana
come on
i mean for god's sake uh
you know that
the prerogatives when it comes to health
and the protection of health are a
national prerogative
and obviously if
austrian citizens have complaints to
make against the measures that are taken
by the austrian government they can go
to the austrian courts to contest these
measures this is definitely not a
question for the european union
oliver
let's not get into an austrian debate
here
may i just add eric these people can go
to the traditional institutions
maybe they'd prefer going and getting
the bloody jab okay no no no because you
can get it for free they should simply
get vaccinated
oliver i'm sorry the press room is not
uh is not a place where we have debates
among journalists okay you're here to
ask questions we're here to provide
answers
as far as we as far as we can i
understand
the of course the sensitivities but
let us make sure we continue operating
that way anna you have a follow up
yes thank you but that is not clear for
me
why the minorities are reduced only to
lgbt because the european commission was
very strong on hungary for example in
protection of this particular
article 2 of the treaty
and now you
three different differently the austrian
minority although they are also minority
and they are also are in their right
because nobody could take away their
right for dignity freedom democracy
equality and uh why you treat uh people
in this different country so differently
because they both are europeans they
both are european union and and one case
you are very strong supporting
minorities uh if it is lgbt and the
other case it's over other minority but
you exclude them from minority list
for me
thank you anna but i have nothing to add
to what i said uh
before and you have
a very clear legal framework when it
comes to the
prerogatives and responsibilities um
related to health and
health measures
have are in the responsibility of member
states and of course they need to
respect the fundamental rights as a set
out an asset out for all eu citizens but
of course austrian citizens have the
possibility of
as i said
challenging those decisions in court if
they so wish
any other questions on kovid
david
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
christian
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
innovation fund just for a second
uh
do you have the list of the projects
because the norwegian projects say that
norway get some money but not which
project it is
i believe as tim has said that you will
find the information in the uh in the
press release
that has been issued today if not i
would ask you to contact tim and he will
give you all the necessary information
other questions for us today
um
hans
yes thank you eric this hans von boyce
with politico i've got a question on eu
uk relations um i'd just like uh you to
give us an update um whether the
commission is still planning um as um
vice president sefzervich
announced last week to to diplomats in
the corporate to give some sort of
briefing um today or this week on
potential
sanctions options um should article 16
be triggered or has this definitely me
been pushed back thank you
thank you we'll take this question and
david will then come back to your other
point which i have forgotten
related to measures in the commission
ayanna in the absence of down
hi hands uh on article 16 i mean our
position is the same as as last week
nothing further to add of course i'm
happy to repeat that we are fully
concentrated on finding practical
solutions that can provide stability and
predictability in northern ireland on
the basis of very far-reaching uh
proposals we have included in the
package we published in on the 13th of
october
these solutions correspond to the
concerns that were raised by
stakeholders on the ground in northern
ireland and vice president zefkowicz
continues to meet on a regular basis
these stakeholders we always very very
much pay attention to to their opinion
and feedback and therefore we are fully
convinced that this package can deliver
a real difference for the people in
northern ireland
while fostering opportunities that
actually uh stem from the dual access to
uk and eu
markets this is also what vice president
sethkovich has said in the statement he
has given on the uh 12th of november
last friday and that of course you can
find on ebs in case you want to watch it
again or the statement is also published
in in the press corner as you know the
technical talks are continuing this week
there is another meeting scheduled on
friday between vice president zefkowicz
and lord frost and therefore at this
stage i would not speculate any further
on article 16.
thank you
i see uh hans you have a follow-up
yes mate then just ask um on the issue
of uh medicines because um the vice
president raised this on friday in his
press conference after the meeting with
lord frost said that we he was hoping
for um if i remember correctly very
concrete uh progress uh potentially this
week so is this still the expectation
that there could be something announced
if things go positively this week on
madison thank you
i'm afraid i cannot prejudge any
announcement what is absolutely correct
is that indeed medicines is a very
important
topic in the mind of people in northern
ireland and of course in our mind as
well as vice president zavkovic has
reiterated on on friday
we are convinced that the issue of
medicines can be considered as a sort of
example on how to approach and solve
together issues uh on on on the
outstanding issues so on the process if
we do manage to reach an agreement on on
medicines we believe that this can then
you know sort of be a model for tackling
other issues um as well therefore the
technical um meetings that are taking
place this week are particularly
focusing on medicines and uh we clearly
hope there will be soon progress but we
will have to wait um
for the the meeting on friday to take
stock of where we are
in these technical stocks uh technical
talks sorry that are ongoing at this
time
thank you
i do not see any other questions for
ariana on eu uk relations
so i come back to balash
for the question asked by
david
on
commission
working methods
in the context of the pandemic in view
of the evolution of the situation and
potential belgian
announcements
[Music]
[Music]
necessary
foreign
foreign